you got a great crew here and I want to
point out our spotlight guy Mike for a
secondary eye there he is
here's the story here's the story I I
came in very early this morning Mike was
already setting up his equipment and
here's the reason I mentioned it Mike
was here very late last night because we
had a double taping how about a hand for
very hard-working guy Mike thank you
thank you
hey thanks Conan you know it's because I
got my allergies under control so I'm
able to sleep better and I get my work
done throughout the day okay well cool
well well good for you thank you yeah
you know ever since I tried zeizel I've
been able to enjoy non-stop 24 hour
relief from seasonal allergies Mike what
are you just doing like a pharmaceutical
commercial right in the middle of the
show is that what you're doing what no
okay well you're actually holding the
product and it really feels like an ad
it's it's it's not an ad we're just
we're just having a conversation about
sisal the allergy relief medication that
works around the clock so it's as
effective an hour 24 as it is an hour
one plus bi takings eyes'll tonight
you'll sleep better and feel better
tomorrow
Mike that really felt like a
pharmaceutical commercial do you even
work here no I don't sisal conan had no
idea we were doing no oh
sisal zero enemies those eyes'll no one
is ever sick going though